[音楽]
[拍手]
4歳からサッカーを始めました
もうすぐサッカーにのめりこんでい
もう小学校の時に少年団に入ってからはえ
練習がある日はもちろん練習がない日の放課後も
学校の休み時間もサッカーはうっかりしたされました
そしていつの日からか夢はサッカー選手になることだ j リーガーだと言うように
なりました
そして今までサッカーを続けてきてことしで23歳になりましたが今も社会人サッカー
という舞台で
同じ運命を追いかけています
朝からトレーニングをして
時間の許す限り自主練習をした後仕事に行きます
仕事から夜帰って来たらもう次の練習のために
ご飯食べて
お風呂入ってストレッチして寝るこれだけです
そういう生活を毎日繰り返しています
どうですかね自分で言うのもなんですけどものすごく
サッカーが好きな奴だと思います僕は
それはその通りなんですけど
ただ僕のサッカーというものは
楽てはならないものではないんです
もう言葉を選ばずに言えば
全然意味のないことだなとするは思っています
でも
でもというかまぁだからこそですけど
僕はサッカーが好きで
サッカーっていうものがこの人生を豊かにしてくれている
という風に
思っています
いやそれがどういうことっていうのを
今日はお話しさせていただきたいと思います
サッカーが無くてはならないものではないなぁと感じ始めたのは大学生の頃です
それまでは
奥井時サッカーっていうのは
かけがえのない必要不可欠なものでした
サッカーでしか友達ができなかったし
サッカーだけしか楽しいことがなかったしサッカーが僕の全てでした
逆になって
一気に世界が広がったような気がしました
自分の周りにサッカーじゃないつながりの友達がいるようになったりとか
サッカー以外のことで生活を楽しむ
自分もいました
サッカー選手じゃない自分っていうものを創造するようにもなりました
それから
自分の身近で就職活動して社会と向き合ってきた人たちがたくさんいました
先輩だったり同期の友達だったよ
そういう人たちを見て
自分はチェリーがになるカラー
就職活動はほとんどしませんでしたけど
でもジェリーがでも社会人になるんだからこのままではいけないと思って自分なりに
学ぼうとしていますん
その中で思ったことは
サッカーって自分が思っている以上に今世界の中では小さいものだなぁって思いました
サッカー選手っていうのはめちゃくちゃかっこいいもんだと思ってるけど
でも
実際の存在としては小さいもうだなと思いました
サッカーがすべてって思っていたのはあ
残念ながら間違いだったんです
だからってサッカーが嫌いになったりとかなかったしずっと一生懸命やってたけど
でも自分の中でのサッカーのあり方っていうものが
確実にこう変わっていきましたん
加えて自分は
進路を選ぶ大学4年生の時に
大卒で j リーガーになれるような選手ではとてもありませんでした
どういう選手が j リーガーになって言ったかっていうと行いとして言うと強豪大学
ずっと1年生からスタメンを張り続けてきて活躍し続けてきた選手たちの中のほんの
一握りの人たちが j リーガーになっていきました
方や
自分を考えてみると立教大学サッカー部に所属した
4年間の中で4年の年の後期0分しか社員でなくて3年半の間
試合に出られませんでした
そんな自分が大卒へ j リーガーになるなんかもこれ絶対無理や等
そういうふうに思ってしまいました
この時
人生で初めて
サッカーを辞めることを考えました
自分にとってのサッカーのあり方
自分自身の選手としての実力
これものを見ているとサッカーを続けるということが
正しいことのようには思えませんでした
何も j リーガーになるだけがサッカーじゃないし
住職すれば安定した生活を送ることが出来るし
ビジネスマンとして
ゼロから調整する
その人生にも
絶対にやりが見つかるなと思いました
サッカーを続けるということが賢いとは思えなかったです
でも
僕は結局サッカーを続けるという選択をしました
この理由っていうのが
サッカーというものが僕にとって
なくてはならないものではなくなっていたからです
これだけ否定的な材料がそろって
やる意味もわからなくなってしまった状況だったけどそれでも
サッカーがしたいという気持ちが僕の中にはあったんです
これはもう
迷うことなく信じていい
本震のやりたい店っていう
思いました
実際
社会人サッカー1年目を経験して
本当に必死でした
サッカーと仕事を両立すること
少ない給料の中でやりくりして生きていくこと
きつになって思うことたくさんありました
別に良い結果が得られたわけでもないです
でも
幸せなんですよね
どんなにきつくてももっと強くなりたいと思って
トレーニングに行くし
もっとうまくなりたいって思いながらどうやったらできるようになるかって考えながら
する練習のバックアップ緩和
ずっと変わっていません
なくてはならないものではないからこそ
幸せだったんです
なくてもいいけどやりたいことこれをやることが人生を
豊かにしてくれるんだなーって言っ
確信しました
こういう自分を見て
やりたいことがあっていいねぇとか夢があって羨ましいわっ
入ってくれる人がいます
でも
これってそんなたいしたことではなくて
別に遊びとか趣味とかと何ら変わりないことだなって言っ
思っています
生きがいとかやりがいとかそういうもんで
くるから難しくなってしまうんだと思います
大人になったら
自分の力で生きていかないといけなくなるし
社会のために自分が働かないといけないし
をやりたいことだけやって得られるような
都市ではないと思うんです
だからこれは何のためにやるんだこれをやる意味はなんだって考えることは
僕もすごく大事だと思います
僕もそういうことを
実際に
サッカーを辞めるかどうかということで考えました
でも
一見無駄に見えるけどやりたいと思うことをやった方が
っていうかそういうものだけが
人生を豊かにしてくれるんだと思います
例えば
別にそれをやって弓あるかわからんし
時間も金もかかるけど俺体で隠したい
筋トレしたいって思うんだったらジム契約して金取りいったらいいと思います
テレビゲームをやる時間ってめっちゃ無駄かもしれないけどそれでもやりたいっていう
ワクワクできるんだったら
行ったほうがいいと思います
一見無駄に見えることをやることでしか
人生は豊かになっていかないと
思うからです
そういうことをやってみるだけでいいんです別に人生を豊かにする事って
そんなに多分難しいことじゃないです
そう考えると別に誰だってキラキラして生きられるやんで
思うんです
スポーツ選手とか芸能人とかユーチューバーとか
を選ばれた人たちのような気がしてしまうけど
絶海らだって
自分のやっていることに
こういう意味があるんだとか本ためにやってるんだってはっきりわかって
るわけじゃないと思うんですでも桜
わかんないけどやりたい好きだからやってる本気でやってるって言うだけだと思います
それだったら別に誰だってできるじゃないですか
やりたいことをやって
キラキラできるのは選ばれた人たちだけだって思いながら
自分に蓋をして生きていくのは
悔しいじゃないですか
僕は悔しいです
なぜなら僕も前選ばれた人をというわけではないからです
僕もサッカーをやる意味っていうのは別にはっきり分からないし何のためにやってるん
だろうって不安になってしまうことも
正直あります
でも
それでもやりたいっていう気持ちだけはずっとあるから
これからも
僕はサッカーを本気であります
別に僕は選ばれた人じゃないけど
j リーガーになって夢を叶えます
そうすることで
この人生というものをもっともっと豊かなものにしていきます
ありがとうございました